well Russell has been visiting a
makeshift camp in andiaman to find out
how people are coping with the aftermath
this place was the biggest stadium in
the city of adiaman and now it's turned
into a tent city over 5 000 people
currently are living here and this is
not the only 10 city in the city of
adiaman there are tons of such makeshift
camps that are spreading across the city
so the displacement here is becoming a
humanitarian issue and authorities are
trying to deal with this crisis I've
talked to the mayor of the city Suleiman
college and ever asked him about the
displacement about sanitation and the
infrastructure problems and the
challenges that they are facing
there's a serious degree of
infrastructure issues of course
including water networks class Network
and electricity network of course
fortunately we have made some
improvements in our water water
resources and water supply maybe 45 50
of the city is now starting the mains
water cancer setup and a lot of people
are still out because because of a large
number of buildings this distracted and
ruined so we are working around the
clock a lot of people are homeless there
are a large number of people who want to
go out of the city they are trying to
arrange their transport to other cities
around the country
was one of the hardest hit cities in
southern turkey by earthquake
1175 buildings have collapsed here and
as a result more than 8 000 people have
died the mayor told me that they're
afraid that this number could go up to
000. indeed wherever you turn in this
city you will see the collapsed
buildings uh blocks after blocks are
leveled down and the the impact of the
earthquake is everywhere and also the
sense of normality among people of this
city is completely lost
well let's go to the capital Ankara
where Cinema is joining us from a red
crescent Aid Center cinema we've just
been hearing how vital the supply of
tents is in amongst all of this in order
to be able to try and house the
survivors Natasha can aim telling us
that torquaya's supply has been depleted
talk us through what's happening Where
You Are
uh Rob uh this is the 10th production
facility of the Turkish red crescents
and they have been doing this for
decades here they are currently is so
intent to deploy to dispatch to the
earthquake hit areas
these tents which are the most vital
need right now until people find a
temporary shelter move for themselves
and these are each tent is 16 and a half
square meters it has separate uh
sections for the family gathering place
and a small room and an entrance we are
told that the material of these tents
are waterproof fireproof and
milder-proof but of course these are
temporary solutions but at least until
the new houses are rebuilt as Turkish
Turkish president promised the these
tents will be one of the temporary
solutions for the people who are going
through tough weather conditions during
winter yesterday Turkish president had a
press conference after the cabinet
meeting he said he will start rebuilding
houses in the earthquake areas after the
end of February within a couple of weeks
and at the initial phase will start with
30 000 houses but of course this is not
enough nothing is enough in the region
right now we're talking about 10 cities
13 and a half million having been
affected by this deadly earthquake and
here in this production center of the
Turkish red crescent the workers are
working around the club they have
increased their employee capacity the
experts working hours everything and we
are told by people who have been working
here for more than 20 years that this is
the first time that nothing is enough no
Personnel is enough and they have
increased full capacity and every day
here they are producing 500 tents and
sending them to the earthquake areas the
the capacity is increasing every day we
are told and these are being sent to the
afat centuries afat is the Turkish
disaster management agency the core
organization that takes that that take
care of the whole Aid campaign
distribution and rescue work in the
earthquake hit areas and these people
here are working hard to able to to be
able to help all those Turkish citizens
some of them maybe their relatives so
that they can they can stay in attend
which can warm them up Rob thank you
very much indeed that's talking to us
from the red crescent Aid Center in
Ankara
well then Tokyo the number of people
being found alive is reducing by the day
but on Wednesday a woman has been pulled
from a building in Karama Mirage
222 hours after the Quakes hit and on
Tuesday a 77 year old woman was rescued
in the city of ajuman after being
trapped for nearly 212 hours
Stephanie Decker has more from Karma
Mirage but other survivors have been
found by rescue crews
men were pulled out of the rubble on
Tuesday but those stories of Joy are
becoming less and less it is
overwhelmingly the dead that our
emerging from their homes where we're
standing these are apartment blocks they
have been cleared but this is as one of
our colleagues described a mass
graveyard the city has become a mass
graveyard it is like this across huge
areas of the city and the buildings that
still stand are broken they are
structurally unsafe their residents will
never be able to go back home so looking
ahead you have the challenge also of how
to house where to house over hundreds of
thousands of people one of the
challenges here it's not just one city
that's been affected by this earthquake
it stretches across major areas of the
southeast certainly in this city hit by
the second earthquake it's epicenter
very close to where we are the people
are devastated many of them still come
believe that this has happened when you
ask them what do you need many will tell
you we need our relatives back I need my
daughter back I need my husband back but
life goes on now many of them are having
to live in tented cities this is a
temporary measure and that's not just
here that's across the entire southeast
of turkey but certainly the stories of
heartbreak and Devastation in their
hundreds of thousands Stephanie Decker
Al Jazeera
Southeastern tarkia